durch meine lieben freunde 48 sind folge
von feed the beast zusammen mit dem hier
ich will dich schlagen ich will die
schlanke snowboard bis zum game baut des
lesers dass wir sie noch nicht gebannt
wenn wir spielen einfach nicht nein wir
machen immer so ein paar tests natürlich
wie das so weiter geht es am nails und
du besonders gern game watch doch noch
ein game mode wird auch noch im ok doch
nicht okay wir haben natürlich wieder
bei twitter gefragt oder bestimmte
geschrieben hashtag fdp werde live die
leute jetzt vorlesen eingeben
das heißt wenn ihr irgendwelche themen
habt wenn ihr irgendwie tipps habt oder
so dann am besten einfach bei twitter
hashtag fgbl über moment #fb glp
schreiben das ist eine gruppenfunktion
im bett wetter das ist kein extra
twitter-account das ist einfach nur eine
gruppenfunktion leute gibt die
mannschaft hat es gibt eine eishockey
wirtschaft nein es ist auch fcb lp damit
fdp genommen nur den fcb das ist ja dann
was anderes ist es so eine blöde gruppe
ihnen wie na ja und was auch viele
meinten war hey du sollst man ein ganzes
steak braten ja aber dazu habe ich in
die box und was sie aussehen sollte hier
oben sieht das jetzt so aus weil der
simon hatte so ein bisschen was
gewaltiges angebot ich würde sagen 'du
könntest dass er theoretisch eigentlich
auch hier umbauen und ja ihr habt es
außerdem auch wieder vielleicht mit
ihrem ruhm quatschen aber jetzt mal was
du jetzt relativ viel quatschen deswegen
lade ich erst mal ganz kurz
ich habe zwei alte screenshots
rausgekramt die mir mal gesendet wurden
also geworden nachrichten gesendet ich
mache natürlich von allen vernünftig
konstruierten nachrichten twitter post e
mails et cetera screenshots und die
werden dann natürlich auch daran
genommen
wirklich glücklich und ja auf jeden fall
vernünftige kommentare beantworte ich
auch immer gerne ich lese ja alle aber
beantworten tue ich weniger für die
vernünftigen und zwar ging es in dieser
nachricht geht darum wie kamen nämlich
von die nach helfer nach fa nach fas
verstehe ist nach fa die haben mir
geschrieben dem crafting feld oben
rechts
sollen wir ein chart reintun da haben
wir natürlich einige in die mitte muss
ein ganz normaler stock weiß was ein
starkes team und weißt du es weißt du es
sah ja ich hab ich habe gold nugget in
sogar 5 stock da hier das ist ein pfeil
so bekommt man nämlich einen zauberstab
mit diesem kann man an einer rechtsklick
auf ein bücherregal machen und dann
erhält man ein buch in dem alles steht
was meine traum kraft erforschen kann
und damit benötigen noch zwei tische und
also ein tisches einer reihe holzes labs
und und unter den linken und unter den
rechten verstehe ich gerade nicht unter
den linken und rechten slap ein road
played with black die tische
nebeneinander hinstellen ins crafting
fällt eine glasflasche ein dienstag und
eine feder was genau damit bezwecken
wollte weiß ich gar nicht aber auf jeden
fall weiß jetzt erst mal wie du deinen
zauberstab da machst du brauchst du gold
nugget chart und stock wollten alles
vertraut machen oder verkleinern ich
glaube wir haben auch so schon
goldnuggets gefunden oder echte machen
wir aus goldbach nochmal goldnuggets
dass die frage ich habe tore debüt
ich habe gold und schwarz sind hier
welche da ich hab das chart erspart und
soja ja genau wie man natürlich ein
einfacher start weil dieses kulows oder
auf jeden fall lustig ja ein steak okay
wenn jetzt die verwaltung sowie eis dick
ein schatten einem gold verwandelt
werden wird in enttäuscht von mir gucken
ich hab's geschafft und wo an zwei
männer handeln hat ich hab' ich habe es
nicht gemacht also austesten
ich werde einfach testen nämlich auch
das mit anderen stars anderen wird
wir brauchen aber auf jeden fall ein
bücherregal ich werde immer das macht
auf dem bücherregal klicken dann wird es
zudem über bücherregal
wir brauchen auf jeden fall ein
bücherregal und was uns auch ganz wieder
geschrieben haben wir können das rad
mitnehmen in den xl in ein extractor
packen und dadurch auch rapper oder dass
die krisen erzeugen was auch sehr sehr
cool ist sauerstoff kutsche ich muss
gerade irgendwie leder finden damit wir
uns bücher oder der school ist der
spyder sein und das geld der denn ich
habe ich hab' ich hab's teil und das
geht ich hab' ich hab' ich hab alles das
bestimmt gefällt das war sogar fast
richtig
erst einmal die ganzen sachen die hier
draußen sind auch erstmal einkriegen
verkratzt ihr auf und außerdem brauchen
wir wirklich bücherregale direkt
brauchen wir oder haben wir schon
bücherregale weil ich habe hier so wenig
leder habe ich schon irgendwo
bücherregale simon baucks kommt im pc
welt an und dann werde ich
wahrscheinlich mit shader aufnimmt dann
wieder alles auch flüssiger laufen vize
biest weil er dem auch bücherregale
gemacht er braucht man bücher für
verzögerungs tisch nein aber so bücher
weiß nicht auf jeden fall wenn ich
irgendwo bücherregal ach so was übrigens
auch leute meinen wir sollten bei kisten
leben und da ich weiß so viele
kommentare durchgelesen wir sollen
kisten dem unter eisen drum packen und
dann haben wir eine heiße kiste und
dandy passt deutlich mehr rein
da hat es geregnet haben einiges
ersparen kisten eine eisen kiste eine
eisen kiste genau das geil war wenig
eisen finde man reisen suchen
seit die schnauze
ihr müsst wissen was sagt er die ganze
zeit gemacht und wir haben kein alter in
der letzten kiste der ich gucke ist das
eisen drin und wir haben so viele kisten
ich wollte auch um alle reisen schaufel
falls seine bauen willst bist ein genug
eisen über das okay warte er in cheste
ich stell dir jetzt mal einfach ich
stelle jetzt einfach hier so hin
manchmal ist gut herr worten die jetzt
mehr platz
nördliche platz bei jeder seiner einzel
kiste eine einzel kiste an einzige rote
doppelt gehst du machst so ja okay dann
versuche ich noch eine zweite zu machen
guck mal vorne einzelgäste doppelte ja
dann bist du eine doppel kissel so groß
weil doppelt so groß wie eine doppel
kippte diese gibt sich im doppel
nee das ist einfach nur eine einzelne
kiste die aber so großes lienen doppelte
aber es auch gut und die kommandanten
einander stellen dass auch cool ist cool
das style und das geld das jetzt alles
was den gibt es zu kate wichtigsten und
das geld das einzige was mich
interessiert kommt mir doch so eine
schaufel ja hier warte ich habe nur eine
rate ich jeder kiste sind ganz viele
reisen schaufeln echt oder warten eben
wunderkiste mancher fühlt du hast hallo
hier kabul im übrigen werden jedoch
seien linken book damit können wir die
sachen verlinken
wenn ihr linkin park nähere infos dann
schreibt uns dass und erst mal du kannst
es erstmal bei twitter gucken
matthias monster hand ich hab das ding
auch schon conny vorgeschlagen dass ihr
projekt in der nächsten zeit noch in
naher zukunft geplant also erstmal noch
mal ganz kurz ich muss sagen sorry
und zwar habe ich mal ganz kurz meine
ganzen sachen die ich so inventar habe
in einer kiste die stelle ich direkt
neben den zauber tisch also da bitte
nicht drangehen dankeschön youtube und
jetzt natürlich unser ganze kisten hier
weil poldi show nächte lang machen so
was für projekte sind geplant jetzt auf
uns beide bezogen oder jetzt oder als
beide sich jeden einzelnen bezogen oder
auch für unsere projekte bezogen auf
unsere projektionen denke mal dass unser
vize bis zu gesa serie erzählt das ist
alleine vorhaben als ich habe ein buch
auf dem boden geschmettert alles kaputt
gemacht
so war das denn egal ob das wäre nicht
so wertvoll hoffe ich zb wieder alle den
kommentaren rum dass ich druck blöd sein
naja also bei mir sind auf jeden fall
noch einige coole serien geplant wenn
ihr diese sie jetzt gerade sieht man
weiß was ich meine so bisschen okay du
willst das mysteriöse aufrechterhalten
ich weiß beim jetzt einiges
interessantes geplant außerdem auch wenn
ich jetzt ferien habe mehr mehr mehr
mehr mehr pvp sachen das heißt einfach
mal so just for fun runde
weil sie nicht irgendwas spiele ich dann
einfach die ganze zeit und ich denke bei
simon das gleiche sein dass wenn du zeit
hast du machst du auch viel mehr serien
ist ja normal halt ein wenig zeit hat er
manchmal ganz viel pvp weil ich lieber
pte ja ich liebe mittlerweile auch pvp
also ich finde das allgemein cool wie
sich minecraft entwickelt hat so dass es
die möglichkeit gibt dass man viel
besser sind gut machen kann weil ich
auch gut sein
also ich denke das wird in die richtung
gehen auf jeden fall so ganz grundlegend
neue sachen kann man natürlich erstens
nie bringen und zweitens beute ist nur
die kiste noch die ich mich einstellen
kann und zweitens wir haben da schon
sachen geplant sage ich mal
so warte ich brauche nämlich noch mehr
ich brauche noch eine eisenkette kannst
du mal ganz kurz in kisten einfach durch
pop irgendwo eisen ist